foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
well good afternoon it is three o'clock
Central four o'clock Eastern you know
what time that is it's time to talk
on the Tony Michaels podcast we have a
special guest for you today I know you
all will know him
everyone out there who's listening we'll
know who this is
there's a little uh political action
committee a pack that has turned into a
media Giant on the left side of politics
they pretty much control all the Trends
on Twitter
every single one of them all the
hashtags the videos the whole nine yards
their name is minus touch and
the the guy who kind of started there's
three brothers there's Ben Brett and
Jordy and Ben has is joining us today on
the podcast I can't believe we have him
here on the podcast and we're gonna ask
him a lot of questions there's been a
lot of questions that have been
submitted
to to uh go over to find out what Midas
Touch is about what their goals are
and really what that podcast is about
over there so let's let's not let's not
waste much time let's let's bring him in
hey Ben how are you good how are you
Tony I'm doing fantastic I'm doing
fantastic so uh give us a little low
down you're with Midas Touch you're
you're you host the legal AF and the
Midas touch podcast you got your
brothers on the Midas touch podcast
you're an attorney as well civil rights
attorney and in the inner entertainment
industry uh you you're tied to names
such as Colin Kaepernick the fire
Festival uh P Diddy and even Clinton so
tell us a little about who you are the
the Midas touch where it came from I
mean were you guys sitting around on the
couch drinking beer and this came up how
did this happen not sitting around
drinking beer we were sitting around in
quarantine in our respective homes this
was during the heart of the pandemic
right around
um you know March of 2020 and we were
terrified like the rest of the nation
was and we couldn't go to the office we
saw these press conferences that Trump
was giving every day telling people to
drink bleach and trying to substitute
his own idiocy for Science and you know
in the day-to-day of Our Lives we're so
busy that we weren't really reflecting
on the state of the country I'm a civil
rights attorney
trial lawyer
represent some of the names that you
listed Brett is an award-winning editor
he was working and running the social
media channels for the Ellen DeGeneres
show our younger brother Jordy was an
award-winning marketer in New York and
we all just said we need to do something
because this is just driving us crazy
and so we started just putting content
out there not knowing what it would be
we didn't even know what a pack was or
what a Super PAC was when we started
just made a video called are you better
off it compared Donald Trump
um uh and and use the famous Reagan ad
of are you better off now than you were
before that got a million views on our
first video and we did another video
called Trump the snake and that took off
and did really well and before we knew
it we were getting video after video We
Grew From zero followers to a thousand
into ten thousand to a hundred thousand
and upward and onward now where across
the various social platforms we've got
millions of followers and likes when you
add it all up over a billion views of
about 550 videos that we produce but you
know we literally started off Googling
like what's a pack and we became a very
successful political action committee
although we LED with our content which
was you know kind of unusual and we kind
of I think revolutionized the way Pacs
uh operate
um in the sense of making this engaging
content and kind of operating like an
entertainment company and then we out of
that Burge into the entertainment
company a media company the Midas media
Network that does podcasts and videos
and a bunch of stuff like that and what
we want to be is we want to fight for
pro-democracy you know we think it's
binary pro-democracy or fascism the
forces of Fox News the breitbarts of
Newsmax of oan
and the gqp are fighting for Fascism and
we view ourselves as fighting for the
values of democracy and making that
interesting and exciting and having
people engaged truly in what's in the
Constitution and not this performative
fascist [ __ ] that the gqp does
so I think that's very interesting
because you guys are unique in that
sense where
as a media company not necessarily as a
pack I guess when you consider the media
company side of it
um everyone kind of steers away from
using the f word not [ __ ]
um fascism [ __ ] two but you know Fascism
and they don't they don't really want to
pin up uh the gqp as you call them I
call them the gqp actually might long
form name form is the Q Anon Maga Trump
humping Evangelical spreadniks which it
takes a lot of breath to say that so gqp
works pretty well but you guys do not
try to steer away from really getting in
the grill of some of the worst of the
worst I mean the Ted cruises the
Marjorie Taylor greens the the Lauren
boberts the Jim Jordans I mean you guys
really want to focus on getting right up
right up close to him and give pile as
much uh stuff on them as you possibly
can as much media on them as you
possibly can through your your not just
your pack but it seems like you know
your media organization with the podcast
that you have and some of the other
content so tell me about tell me about
what your goals are not just for minus
touch but like like what what what does
it look like for 2022 because we're
going into one of the craziest election
cycles that I think we've had we look at
2016 and and 2020 and I don't think
those even hold a candle to what's going
to happen in 2020. I want us to be to
play whatever role we can play as three
brothers who built this network to make
a difference there are a lot of groups
that are doing such great work
especially local community groups we saw
what Stacy Abrams did in Georgia and
other groups like that across the
country who deserve the utmost credit
where we come in is we though try to
help in kind of any other areas where we
could be influential in our messaging
and you look at Georgia we wanted to
frame that race not just react
but frame the race as looting Lefler and
chicken Purdue and I remember speaking
with Democratic Consultants when they
said well what's your plan in Georgia
you know after the success that we had
in the general elections and I said
chicken Purdue and looting Leffler
what the hell does that mean right what
does that mean I said that's the theme
that we need to push that he's a chicken
and she steals and that that is how we
frame the message and in the past the
gqp they're now the gqp back then I
guess they were called Republicans or
something like that they were very good
at framing those issues simple direct
messaging but they would have to lie if
we could tell the truth but also be
blunt and direct and not speak to the
Ivory Tower so it's always good to talk
to the Ivory Tower sometimes but not
when we're trying to message to voters
what's at stake
um and so that's just kind of a
microcosm strategically of what we do
and it's not just framing content around
that we also put boots on the ground we
had an incredibly successful canvassing
effort that we did in Suburban areas of
Georgia we weren't really focused on the
urban areas and Stacy Abrams did an
incredible job there but we focused on
areas where we knew that Trump had won
and we knew that they were gqp territory
but we wanted to increase Democratic
margins in those specific areas with our
canvassing efforts enough to help offset
so that when the gains were made in the
urban areas there wouldn't be a
concomitant offset in the Suburban areas
and I think we did a good job there but
we did a text message campaign 5 million
text messages
um you know Nationwide and we have such
a great database of uh individuals to
send text messages to now so even for
example in the Gavin Newsom recall where
we were able to activate tens of
thousands of Californians through text
messages we got about a 45 to 50 percent
response rate on our text messages and
if you ask text message companies that's
like an unheard of number because most
people get the messages and they go I
guess in your words Tony [ __ ] them I'm
not gonna respond [ __ ] that [ __ ] right
yeah but we got 40 people responding
saying we're in it we're we're activated
and so we want to frame the issues not
just react
and then we want to put resources in
strategic areas when these elections are
decided by close margins to be the
difference and then we want to let
people know it's at stake it's life or
death we don't want to sugarcoat it and
the gqp will kill you your family your
children your grandparents and that's
what's at stake in the selection is that
and you look at the policies
most Americans by significant numbers 65
70 support Democratic policies so we
have to align the interest with the
political party because it there should
be there should be that Synergy right
there but you also got to sell the
message and I like that you brought up
the California recall because that's
really to me I look at the California
recall and I think that's the first real
election as it were
um that we have to gauge the country now
a lot of people say oh it's California
it's blue well that's that's not exactly
true I mean Gavin Newsom isn't like the
most popular governor of governors of
all governors right I mean he's he
wasn't
but I mean he he basically in for all
intents and purposes uh clobbered Larry
Elder and three to three to one and the
reason why is because uh not just Midas
Touch but like you said a lot of
organizations occupy Democrats
um uh resist programming I don't know I
think you guys had a lot of their videos
on they on earth like just troes and
trolls of trolls of Larry Elder being
trumpism before trumpism was cool right
I mean he was basically saying the most
vile [ __ ] that Trump and and the gqp
says today he was saying that 25 years
ago
and and everyone's you know he used to
be an outlier and now he is the the
embodiment of trumpism you know stuff
like scoffing at the Ada saying he would
vote against the Civil Rights Act uh you
know just basically
piling the slave owner should get
reparations yeah well and and [ __ ]
all over the middle class by saying
there shouldn't be a minimum wage and I
mean I mean just absolutely absolutely
uh being trumpism before trumpism was
cool that's kind of how I framed it up
and I think when you couple that with
what California has been able to do with
the pandemic because they are I mean
they're one of the largest economies in
the world and you guys spoke about it
today on your podcast now we're going to
air this later on but you had your
guys's podcast today and you talked
about this that not only not only are
you guys having in California having
some of the lowest uh infection rates
but you're having some of the lowest
unemployment rates I mean unemployment
is lowering out there as the pandemic is
coming to an end in California and
that's only because someone out there is
doing their [ __ ] job now rather you
like how they're doing it or not uh
that's a question but it seems like in
an election a lot of people would have
voiced their opinion rather they thought
someone was doing a good job or not
doing a good job and it really seemed
like from the results of the recall that
maybe they don't like Gavin Newsom but
they definitely do not want the
alternative and do you think that's the
key to some of these elections in 22 is
not exactly who who our you know
quote-unquote our candidate is but hey
do you want trumpism do you want this in
your state do you want this in your
District do you want a trump Senator is
that the aim or do you think it's hey we
have this great candidate forget about
trumpism I think it's both I mean you
need to have great candidates and we
can't ignore that it's important to put
up people who could win but as Gavin
Newsom said
while the americ while Californians
voted no on the recall and it was a win
for Gavin Newsom look at what
Californians voted yes for
um they voted yes for their health they
voted yes
um to help the country with climate
change and that climate change is real
they voted yes for the economy they
voted yes for the right to choose they
voted yes on issues that overwhelmingly
matter to Americans and so we have to
pick great candidates so that's an
important fact but we also need to
hammer home
um the gqp links to trumpism I'll give
you an example let's go east
to Virginia
um in the race where the Republican
nominee for governor is this guy young
Kim
um and junkin's private Equity guy but
um to appeal to the gqp base openly
endorsed death scientist's view about
penalizing schools that want to have
mask requirements at their schools which
is very unpopular in Florida you have to
say those things to be popular amongst
the gqp echo chamber but Americans by
and large want I mean I think I saw the
Fox News poll today we talked about it
on the podcast
67 percent of Americans are for Mass
requirements in schools and so when you
have someone like Younkin who tries to
put on if you see Junkin in these
debates you know he tries to act like a
moderate and he's very careful and
shrewd with his wording but then he
aligns himself with DeSantis he says
what an honor it is to be endorsed by
Trump and those two things we gotta
drill we got to drill that home for the
voters that okay well what that means is
you have zero judgment that means you're
going to make uh Virginia schools unsafe
that means that you support
insurrections that means that you have
no respect for Virginia law enforcement
at all because obviously the
insurrectionist attacked Capitol police
officers and metropolitan police
officers who are closely aligned with
Virginia law enforcement based on the
proximity and you gotta Hammer that
message there and we got to focus on the
gqp is the party of the boberts Marjorie
Taylor greens we released the video
today that re-edited the Marjorie Taylor
Green video where she's got the gun and
she blows up the car that says social
realism on it and we changed the wording
to show what it is that Marjorie Taylor
green wants to destroy she wants to
destroy your ability to live on planet
Earth but she wants to destroy uh free
education she wants to destroy the
ability to rebuild our infrastructure
she wants to destroy democracy and so
you gotta Hammer home the messaging too
that these are the faces of the gqp the
gates or the gets Matt gets Gates those
people of the world that's who they are
now these are real bad people who are
out of touch with the values of
Americans and we have to be very careful
in our language I think too and one of
the things that we always reinforce on
the podcast is we use repetition gqp gqp
gqp we talk about how the gqp is not
conservative I don't like to view this
party the gqp as conservatives because
there's nothing conservative about
supporting insurrections there's nothing
conservative about being anti-vaxx and
spreading crazy disinfo that's the least
conservative position I don't even
really like to call them the right
they've been shrewd at framing uh
Democrats as extremists and putting
these labels on but it's the furthest
thing from the truth when you really
break down what the issues are and
Democrat leaders being thoughtful
intelligent people across all these
policies we got to be true too we got to
say though the gqp are terrorists the
gqpr extremist the gqp want to kill your
children when you know Latin Americans
know what's at stake
boy you got I got notes Here for to
unpack everything that you just said
because it is uh I'm I'm with you on a
lot of things there number one I I do
think that the the Virginia race is the
next Battleground to prove that this
country does not want this gqp domestic
terrorism trumpism they just they don't
I think that's the next real measurable
race that is gonna I mean do you agree
with that that's probably the next
measurable race in votes that we'll have
now the next thing is uh because you
guys have been talking about this and
I've been talking about this on my
content
um you guys frame it a little different
than me but what I say is is we are now
at the intersection of WrestleMania and
real life right and on one corner
there's the Ivermectin store
and on the other corner there's the gqp
headquarters like literally it is
everything they can do to just appeal to
the Facebook fans the Facebook feed
store pharmacy fans right uh you
mentioned DeSantis Rhonda Santos down in
in Florida and basically a total rebuke
from the the Fox News poll showing that
67 percent
not only disagrees with that but once
they're children healthy I can't
understand how anyone in this country
stands around looking at each other go
yeah we want our children not to be
healthy in schools like since when did
that become a value of this country and
you get to back to the Marjorie Taylor
green you just had so much there that I
want to unpack but the main thing is the
Wrestlemania real life the fan you know
because that's what she's doing when
she's shooting in a car and blowing it
up is this WrestleMania thing that the
Lauren boberts the DeSantis the Ron the
Rand Paul's uh Ted Cruz right this this
WrestleMania I think um Eric swallow was
on your podcast a while back and he kind
of talked about he told a story that Ted
Cruz came in the bathroom and they were
like pissing at the urinals or something
together and Ted Cruz looks at him go oh
you're doing a real good job and he's
like what the hell are you talking about
like I'm I I'm destroying you and he's
like yeah that's part of the that's part
of the show and it's like they really
really are it is a performance for the
Facebook fans it's a performance so that
their fans go on social media and just
type out crazy nonsense like the horse
dewormer stuff the I mean today you've
seen it with Chris Rock he comes out he
admits he has covid and he says go get
the vaccine and they completely distort
what he was trying to say like they have
no nuanced uh way of looking at a
statement from someone like Chris Rock
where they can even determine that what
he's trying to say is hey I probably
would die if I wouldn't have had the
vaccine go get it but nope that's not if
he had covet and he's saying go get the
vaccine those two things don't mix so we
have to get on Facebook we have to get
on social media and be as crazy as we
possibly can be crack beers like Stone
Cold Steve Austin over our heads and
yell and scream crazy stuff so that way
that the Facebook fans are pleased I
mean do you think that's part of this
because everyone calls it Division I
don't think there's a lot of division I
just think
there's the crazies and they're all
they're they're trying to placate to the
fans right I think in a liberal
democracy you'll always have a portion
of the population 25 to 30 percent of
the population that no matter what you
do you can't reason with them but in the
past one of the things that have made
Democratic institutions so successful is
that generally leaders on both sides or
in multi-party political systems all the
various different
um sides have kind of come together and
said here's what's important for our
country let's not let those voices
um Define who we are and with the
Ascension of a psychopath so you know
narcissistic crazy person like Donald
Trump we gave the nation the Cheeto dust
mobster the Cheeto dust mobster that's
what I gave that quarter and the problem
when you do that is is that the
craziness then metastasizes because when
he brings Air Force One and uses the
symbolism that makes America truly a
special country and creates the show
you're able to actually increase That
Base that's why we saw more people vote
for him uh the next uh you know in the
most recent election although there were
far more Americans motivated to make
sure this psychopath was out of office
um but that's generally what the problem
is is that now you have these wannabe
trumps these you know all the gqp
leaders who want to emulate those crowds
and that environment and the
their attack how how just infatuating
that experience was to to them they
don't do it half as as
compelling As Trump is with the crazy
base
um
DeSantis tries to do a good impression
he's got the he's got the suit and he's
got the hair he's start he hasn't dyed
it blonde yet but he's got the hand
gestures down have you noticed that he
tries to do the Cadence he really he
really tries to really do the best Trump
impression that he can I mean it's it's
Insanity that we are in this position
where a reality TV show star
a a fake successful business person
because let's call it what it is he he
and we're gonna find this out with this
case in New York and we could probably
talk because I I listened to a little
bit of your legal AF uh from this
weekend and you guys talked about
um
a little bit about some of these cases
but today we had some news uh that Alan
weisselberg might see more charges
there's possibly going to be more people
charged
um in the Manhattan DA's case uh which
who knows exactly where that's going to
lead I I actually believe that that's
all set up and and you're you're an
attorney I'm not but I believe that
that's all predicate for federal
referrals for other uh other crimes that
might be related to Tom Barrack and uh
and then a certain Inaugural Committee
and it's uh it's a search for those
referrals to federal courts but I mean
you know we never know exactly what's
going to happen because you got Rudy
Giuliani in the mix there too
um you know it all seems all these dots
seem to connect with these with these
scumbags you know but but I guess when
you see how he tore down
um not just Norms but he made the
presidency a reality TV show I mean
that's what it was because Donald
Trump's always been fake it till you
make it type stuff right and that is not
exactly how a presidency an oval office
or a country needs to be ran he's still
doing the fake it till you make it stuff
even after being president he he tries
to put out these statements uh he he
totally he totally misses the mark on a
lot of them and a lot of people aren't
even paying attention even his
supporters don't even pay attention to
his to his statements I mean he is a
buffoon and he's he's he's not
uh he's not the leader everyone thinks
he is that's my opinion I actually think
he's not the Pied Piper he's actually
the one
toting what they want him to say he's
always came out said exactly what they
want to hear he keeps saying what they
want to hear and that's what Ron
DeSantis that's what Larry Elder was
saying they kept they just said what the
Facebook fans want them to say because
like you said there's about 20 30
percent of people that are the
quote-unquote crazies in this country or
people you're not ever going to please
rather they're on the right they're on
the left or they're just out in la la
land which that's mostly where they are
I believe that in our country's history
we've had these people spread out over
the toast the Jelly's been nice and
spread thin you know you had your flat
earthers you had your JFK conspiracy
theorist but now they're all in one spot
they're all in one spot and it's TR and
it's and for whatever reason they have
made this guy like a god they've made
him a God and I think it's that reality
TV show where they bought into that he's
actually a billionaire
um I know I don't know do you do you
think think that they actually see him
as like the cult leader or is it just
he's the placeholder for their cult that
they want to have that is on the Libs no
matter what because we've seen today
that the uh Breitbart had a story about
you know oh it's this is all the
Liberals know that they want to own the
libs so they're trying to kill him off
do you think it's a lot of that I mean
or is it really Donald Trump is the
leader of this movement
I think a lot of people in complex times
are scared and they're vulnerable
um and there's a lot of information
that come at them and the question
becomes what do you do with that fear
and Donald Trump has been good at and I
think Mary Trump said this on our
podcast has been good at converting the
fear
into anger and anger at other people
and that a group of people who have felt
um left out who feel
like
uh they can't fit in
um Donald Trump has basically given them
the excuse to act out their most evil
heinous nature and to point their finger
at anyone else and to hate somebody else
versus bring them together you know and
I think that's the that's the biggest
problem I think back to
the John McCain Obama race where the
woman stood up took the microphone and
called Obama a Muslim which by the way
there's nothing wrong if he wasn't must
right right but John McCain took the mic
and I corrected her and just said look
she's not a Muslim and at that moment he
could have stood there and became the
same way death santis stands there as
someone stands behind the Florida seal
and talks about how uh mRNA changes your
DNA and just complete [ __ ] lines
um you know a leader would step in there
and say no no no no I'm a fiduciary of
the state I need to take action and
that's what's been totally lost in the
Republican party you know and as my
brother was saying today on the podcast
Republicans can do everything wrong and
no one gives a [ __ ] because they're EXT
their bar is set so low the bar for a
Democrat is so high and Democrats have
to pass the most transformative
legislation for imaginable and if they
fall short you know but that's what we
should aspire to be ultimately right we
should aspire to provide Health Care to
everyone to try to get as many people
educated as we can and provide free
college education
um and to make government work for
people and so it's a worthy fight for us
to have but it's also important that we
point out to all Americans who's
fighting for them and who's not well you
know that's a good point and it leads me
to uh some of my closing questioning
here from you is is because we're going
to have a lot of elections in 2022 and
you just said because you are right and
your brothers are right that Republicans
do just get to sit on their asses I mean
Mitch McConnell's like debt ceiling well
you handle that [ __ ] you know we're not
going to do any of that I mean they
literally do not have to do anything
because they do not have any
consequences as long as long as they own
the libs you know whatever the hell that
means
but back to the races and actually
getting stuff done because if Democrats
are the only ones that are going to do
the heavy lifting for 70 75 maybe even
80 percent of the country Democrats got
to win some some races and there's going
to be a lot of redistricting
um with with the new census and how that
all went down it seems like it could be
in Republicans favor but what I want to
ask you is is there one race that stands
out to you that everyone thinks at this
point is completely unwinnable there's
no way any Democrat can win this but you
think it's completely winnable there are
candidates that can come out of a
primary and can win that race do you see
a race like that at this point to give
Democrats hope that hey if we can win
that race we can we can win the ones
we're supposed to win
well I I I wouldn't count out the race
and uh a lot of these races in uh
Georgia
um even the race where by all accounts
Marjorie Taylor green you know should
win based on being in an entirely
Republican District
um you know we had on one of her uh the
Democratic Challengers and you know I'd
be interested to see there uh what you
know in the last time Marjorie Taylor
green ran she ran unopposed and you know
I think that'll be a closer race but
will tell us a lot because you know I
think that the people of Georgia are
embarrassed by her I mean I can give you
easier ones and just say like Lauren
bobbert's gonna lose
um want a bipartisan Commission
redistrict in her area but I think that
even if there wasn't redistricting in
Colorado where bobert's from she would
have lost people were sick and tired of
her that would give you a good indicator
you know and to some extent I mean I'm
happy it was redistricted right by the
bipartisan Commission because we
definitely need to sociopath out but at
the same time that would have been a
good example though of just people
saying look I'm not we're not for this
but what we're going to come out with us
might as touch is something that we're
calling the blueprint and the blueprint
is going to be kind of our comprehensive
strategy
um of uh dozens of congressional races
where we think that Democrats can keep
their seats and we're Democrats can
ultimately win you know I I you know I I
say this
because I don't want to like give away
an important point but I think it's
worth mentioning which is that
the current gqp base
is a very unreliable voting block
Republicans used to be a reliable voting
block because it was usually elderly uh
well-educated
um and kind of all of that's flipped
right because you know and so you have
people who don't even believe in the
election process and then they claim
it's rigged three days before the
elections and it's a weird it's really
weird that that's an approach to
um elections when you
undermined the system itself and so I
think if you look at what happened in
Georgia
um in the two Democrats winning uh
Against All Odds in areas that were
heavily Republican I do think that the
Democrats not only will hold on uh to
their seats in 2022 but my prediction is
Democrats will have slight gains in the
house in 2022 because at the end of the
day the American people are going to
look at it and they're going to say I'm
not going to I'm not going to vote for
these psychos who are going to you know
potentially kill my family members and
kill my children whether they expressed
that overtly whether they go into The
Ballot Box or mail-in and just say yeah
I'm voting for myself to live that's
that's what's on the line right well and
they I think ultimately people want
someone who's actually going to do
something for their District as opposed
to you know just get likes and and
retweets and you know be a troll on
social media I mean let's face it that's
what Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bobert are is they're they're social
media trolls at this point that have
congressional seats it's a shame but
that's that's the truth in the matter I
mean Matt gatz is the same damn way in
Florida he's just a social media troll
that holds a congressional seat it's
it's kind of sickening so I think a lot
of people are going to do that but but I
I do like what you said about the long
game short game because I think that's
something that has totally flipped in
this country and Donald Trump did it for
him you know it's it they they selected
him they they made him their candidate
they made him the president but he
ultimately made them play short game
politics where Republicans since really
the 1970s have been been playing long
game politics in this country where
they're more focused on blaming an
election that they lose on fraud before
it even happens and really uh
restricting their voting block to
believing that the elections rigged no
matter what the Democrats are going to
rig it up which is a horrible long-term
that's a that's a horrible long game
really that's a short game in politics
right and short game in elections
because you're only focused on the next
the next one that you're supposed to say
is a fraud right as opposed to a long
game of having a message and actually
instituting I mean Republicans have
owned state legislators for almost
almost well almost two decades but
really since Barack Obama took took
office they were able to really use that
fear like you said earlier to play the
long game and they're not playing long
game anymore they're only playing short
game and I think it's going to hurt them
in the long run but you never said you
never said One race you you kind of
dodged me there on which one which one
you think everyone thinks is not
winnable that you think and I know I
don't want you to place a bit but I mean
is there a race you think that Democrats
can win that everyone's counting out now
that that will be the surprise race
Maybe
oh I I think that while it's not a
congressional race I think death Santos
is going to get clobbered I don't think
I think that santis is going to lose by
um five to eight points and I think he's
got good can I mean you guys had uh
Kristen was it last week or the week
before I don't remember Chris then we
had freedom zoomed in I mean both really
yeah that's that's right that's right
real and and uh Florida deserves to
choose which one of those is going to be
their Democratic nominee
um and they'll I'm sure they'll do a
very classy job of trying to determine
who actually is going to run against
Ronda santis but I think either one of
those candidates can beat him and
especially seeing right now I think
Chris is up at 10 points or over 10
points onto santis which is not good uh
for DeSantis so I I don't know what Beto
Beto O'Rourke seems like he may enter
the race now rather he ends up being the
Democratic candidate in Texas or not I
guess you know the race will tell that
the primary but I think he might even
have a good chance in Texas uh and Texas
is kind of a wild card though it seems
to be getting more and more purple but
even this uh the the 2020 race it didn't
beat proved to be as purple as what
Democrats would want it to be
no doubt about it and but I I think
you're going to see a shift in
Governor's races I think you're going to
see the Democrats hold the house and
look
historically the Democrats should lose
the house in 2022 that's kind of every
election after one political party takes
the the White House yeah Barack Obama I
mean just in recent history Barack Obama
and Donald Trump boom boom they lost
they lost their midterm so what happens
if Joe Biden wins his midterm what
happens does that give him more
political Capital than he even has now
you think what what because the Dems are
going to increase their the the Senate
um seats as well like I I think you
probably get a plus three plus four so
we're at 53.54 in the Senate you think
yeah and I don't think we have to be as
beholden to mansion and Cinema
um and if you look at those races
generally a lot of Republicans
because they're sick and they're
thinking about their legacy now too A
lot of these Republicans in the Senate
and they're retiring because they're
like I ain't running I ain't running
again if I run I have to say some real
crazy [ __ ] and I've been doing a great
job
um you know I've I've have a a legacy a
career I'm not going down in this
trumpism crazy stuff and that's why
they're like [ __ ] it [ __ ] them I'm not
doing it right well you know you know
you just look at the race here in
Missouri and I know Lucas Koontz is one
of the Democrats
um that that will be in the primary but
you look at the Republican side and you
have you have like a [ __ ] bag like Billy
long
um down in the the Southwest part of the
the he's a king he's the kind I don't
know if you know Billy longer you watch
Billy long but
um just horrible horrible horrible human
being but he's not the most horrible
human being in the race you have Eric
greitens and and you have the the the
lawn yard gnome with the AK-47 or
whatever he thought he was gonna do you
know you have that chucklehead from St
Louis
um you have him running who Parson
pardoned him from his chart his gun
charges I mean this is and that's what
they're going with in Missouri now I
don't know if Missouri would or would
not elect but I can't even imagine
having any one of those Republicans as a
United States Senator anywhere not just
not just Missouri but anywhere I can't
imagine it but we do have Lauren boberts
and Marjorie Taylor Greens in the
Congress so I mean I don't know do you
think races like that are winnable too
just because the candidates are so
freaking horrible I mean just just
horrible that it could be Mickey Mouse
running against them and they've got a
chance even in a place like Missouri
Democrats run smart elections and I
think the California blueprint is a
smart way to win the election newsom's a
fine candidate he's got his issues but
he's a good candidate and then you have
these psychos who don't kill the lightly
lightly putting it right yeah you have
these psychos who who are incompetent
and and couldn't even lead you know uh
you know they couldn't even lead the
book club in a mental ward
um these are
and these are people who are running for
serious seats and so you've got to just
point that out to the people and you
know and and Hammer at home that these
people are dangerous and we gotta we
gotta make sure our kids lives are are
saved and that man's gonna kill you or
that woman's gonna kill you that
person's gonna kill you
um it's got to be that Stark and right
and we can talk High we could talk high
brow stuff right we could talk policy
um but we also have to talk and and use
some of the tactics in the past where
the gqp would use false information we
can't do that we need to use the truth
but we need to forcefully push these
messages stay consistent stay on brand
always be guided by the truth and not
lies but let the people know what's at
stake well that brings me to a good
point because then you should watch my
podcast every Wednesday a three o'clock
Central four o'clock Eastern and watch
all the Midas touch podcasts because
they bring the truth and they don't give
a [ __ ] they will use the
constitutionally protected word [ __ ] I I
listen to it today and they they use the
word [ __ ] otherwise I wouldn't have been
on If he if he was scared [ __ ] him [ __ ]
them so so uh one last thing before we
go and I know all because we didn't talk
about the minus Mighty so I want to ask
you what the Midas Mighty is but the
ultimate question before we go is I want
to know this and I know this is probably
a controversial topic and I know all the
mightiest Mighty are going to want to
know this
which one which one is your favorite
brother
which one is Michael
Jordan's my favorite brother uh okay
okay it's me Brett so that's an easy one
so Jordy it goes Jordy Brett and then me
in that order but jordy's number one
okay and then the Midas Mighty is
the name that the community of Midas
Touch supporters have kind of given
themselves uh to describe the advocacy
that they do which I kind of describe as
accidental activists people who were not
necessarily didn't necessarily view
themselves as being political who have
now felt this kind of desire and need to
um help wherever they can and so there's
uh if you go on Twitter there's a whole
community of people who even change
their Twitter names to you know Midas
Aaron and Midas Kesha and Midas
um you know all these different all
these different names
um you know Midas and Midas Sally
um and they go out there and we have a
number of chapters of Midas University
chapters we have a college program
called Midas University there's a about
23 chapters and colleges and
universities across the country there's
a chapter called Midas Varsity Blue
which is a high school chapter that
focuses on registering voters who just
turn 18 but also inspiring high
schoolers before they turn 18 to
fight for democracy and it's just this
community of people who communicate with
each other share ideas and do their best
to
support our country and there's been
rarely before on the Democratic side
kind of like a fun group to talk about
politics
um you know the right wing has all these
kind of crazy wacko groups
um that kind of form these communities
where they spread disinfo so me and my
brothers you know want to embrace the
community that tells the truth and truly
supports the values of this country and
does some great work give you an example
I talked about the text message campaign
earlier in the show but during the
general election we were able to send I
think about 5 million text messages
within a matter of a week based on all
the volunteers that we had who identify
within the Midas Mighty movement you'd
have people sending like 15 000 text
messages a day you know and the
Consultants who we worked with said
we've never seen like even if you had
hundreds and hundreds of people that
level of Engagement and passion and
that's kind of part of what we do too is
like we wanna we wanna create this
community but then at the right time
activate the community to then get
people to vote and if you're talking
about tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands of like truly truly passionate
people who dedicate you know who
self-identify as being like Midas as one
of the main things they identify with
those people are going to spread the
word of democracy around and so it's
kind of cool to have that and they've
you know just a motivating force to have
that that kind of community that we
we've we're proud to be a part of it
well that's awesome because I really
think it is going to take those
communities
um to win some of these races in 2022
because like I said earlier I think uh
16 in in 2020 are not going to hold the
candle to the battlefield that is going
to sue in these uh elections in 2022 it
is going to be uh it's going to be
something else because it's just going
to be everywhere all the time and it's
going to be non-stop so having that
Community there in the community you
guys have built along with other groups
out there like you said not to ignore
other groups out there that have their
communities and I know there's a lot of
overlap but that's what it's going to
take is activate activation and
engagement in those voters and in those
places where you wouldn't expect
the left wing or the liberals or the
libtar whatever you whatever anyone
wants to call them to engage and
actually win elections so I appreciate
you coming on the podcast
and I appreciate the answer now everyone
knows the answer to who's the favorite
brother so it's a majority yeah okay
okay well you know that that's fair
enough that's fair enough I appreciate
you coming on thanks buddy and one last
thing why don't you plug all the podkits
you got like 500 podcasts just that
you're on so why don't you give us a
good Shameless plug here and then I'll
I'll take you off so we've got the Midas
media Network that has the Midas touch
podcast that I host with my brothers we
have our legal podcast legal AF we have
a podcast called Kremlin file that
focuses on the rise of Putin and the
influence of uh kind of putinism across
the world where executive producers of a
podcast called
um Maya culpa and then we've got a
podcast that focuses on the voices of
gen Z called zoomed in and we've got a
bunch of other podcasts
um that we'll be announcing in the next
few weeks
awesome thanks for joining me I really
appreciate it everyone go check out they
can find all that stuff at
minustouch.com or on the Twitter account
or Facebook page I'm sure it's all out
there go to minus touch.com and find all
that good stuff thanks a lot Ben thanks
for joining me we'll talk to you soon
thanks for having me yep
all right
Midas Touch here on the Tony Michaels
podcast I even got him to say [ __ ] him
at least at least there's at least four
or five times he said [ __ ] them and
that's that's what we're looking for on
the Tony Michaels podcast is to give it
to you straight
so we're going to air this on Friday at
three o'clock Central four o'clock
Eastern just like we do all the other
special guest episodes so it will be
right here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
live and at the same very same time
because it's a special special guest
episode it will go up on all the podcast
directories just as they all do so check
it out follow us on all the social
medias
and let us know how we're doing oh and
before I forget one last thing [ __ ] them
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them